you must win is when you're when the
other team has three wins and uh and if
you lose you're done that's a must win
um I have faith that our team can win uh
any series as long as we have more games
to play a lot of self-inflicted wounds
um across the board and you hate that
you have to keep learning that lesson at
this stage of the season but
he did and now it's about how he uh how
to respond
man Golden State game two 127 to 100
over the Lakers Lakers turn around game
three 127 to 97
by definition Steve cursing yeah this is
not must win
but is it
I think it is you never want to be down
3-1 because you know
then the next game you have to play well
so you know they listen we know they're
going to bounce back they're they're
definitely battle tested you know
usually when you smack Golden State
around they come back with the Vengeance
and they play well so I think it's a
must win for for La you don't want to
don't want to mess around with a team
like Golden State I don't like talking
about this but if those two Splash
Brothers get going and you know take a
take a step back in the past
you know series could be over so you
know they were hot the other night
especially in Golden State they didn't
really shoot the ball too well last
night so you know you talk about most
wins I think it's a must win for the
Lakers to let them know that we're
serious 3-1 and you know I think if they
get the 3-1 if A.D plays like he played
game one and game three if he plays like
that
close this team out so you know the
Lakers definitely need to you know take
care of business tomorrow the the
Anthony Davis thing is fascinating to me
um
if he plays great
the Lakers are going to win
but he's due for another bad game
tomorrow
I mean it's so
why do you think that could ever happen
to someone
not me not not to you know
like you say you go from 40 to 11 to 15.
a great like how does that happen a
great player does not have a player
who's talented
who's inconsistent can have those
variations you can never be a great
player
if you've given me 40
and 15. why does a talented player you
were talented how did you turn it into
greatness well it's it's all mental like
I enjoyed kicking guys ass that's what
make you a star like they can't like
when you when you're a star you're
better than 99 of the people in the
world you should want to showcase I
couldn't wait to get to the gym
especially during the playoffs when you
get days off everybody's watching like
like Shaq says all the time your numbers
should go up during the playoffs like if
you're averaging 24 during the regular
season you used to be close to 30 with
days off and things like that every
every great players I number should go
up and if I had a bad game
my 26 28 was going to be 20. it wasn't
going to be 11 or 12 and that's where
it's perplexing about the end of the
Davidson because I'm sitting here
watching that's how stupid some of these
guys are on television after game after
game one Aaron Davis was great in game
two they're like oh man those Warriors
they changed it up dream on guard
Anthony Davis and he was physical I'm
like yo man they found the Davis play
they can't guard him and you see him
come out in game three and says yo man
they can't and now
I can't wait to watch that game tomorrow
night that's not to answer your
questions or anyone London ask your
questions call being comfortable
right because of being great is
uncomfortable hey damn I had 40 in game
one I got to get it again I got to get
it again I gotta get it again so he's
you know he's oh I had a great game the
best of my Hall of Famer and his journey
is going to be there it's comfortable so
you know again when you're with a child
is as one of the greatest is a
uncomfortable feeling has not had
consecutive 20-point games in these
playoffs that's crazy oh hell no that's
crazy and they play they play game four
tomorrow night here on TNT